[Laughter]  yeah i didn't quite say that  no black is just completely stuck if the  black bishop takes the white pawn the  bishops the knight will they will  disappear but white will be a pawn up in  the king of porn and game easy win  and black's king is stuck defending the  white left pawn uh if you don't capture  it so  look at that face just look at him i  mean he's uh  just getting ready to resign i think  yeah or lose on time maybe he doesn't  even look close to making a move okay  maybe here he comes getting himself  psyched up for the tie breaks that are  imminent yeah we're all going to be here  for some more games extra entertainment  yeah dude about to resign and there we  go a result there we go this means in  five minutes blitz tie breaks will start  this also means magnus carlsen will be  in solid  after today because he will get at least  one point if he loses the target breaks  two points if he wins and the tie breaks